et vous vous êtes né alors en chine dix
jours avant le début la révolution
culturelle en 1966
donc vous êtes né pratiquement en même
temps que cette révolution culturelle
on pourrait imaginer que vous avez
échappé à cause de votre jeune âge aux
retombées épouvantable de cette
révolution culturelle même pas du tout
l'irruption des gardes rouges dans votre
famille vous avez quel âge quand parce
que vous la raconter donc vous en
souvenez vous avez quel âge à l'âge 4 4
ans c'est un jour
autant donc en train de jouer avec
l'agresseur tranquillement parce que
dans ma maison aussi en mai joncynois et
il est un petit cours tant que ces lacs
tous les jours j'ai joué avec ma soeur
est cependant ces moments là que mes
parents qui est à renier nos en train
d'emprunter cet été avec mes
grands-parents et c'est pendant ces
moments là que tout à coup en temps
elles sortent pru samedi avec crier avec
le puits qui quelque chose taper sur un
boire tout ce qui s'est passé comme
comme un rêve très utile car c'est une
gauche qui font irruption chez vous et
qui casse tout et puis qui s'empare de
vaud de vos parents et qui déjà tous
août et humilie parce qu on les rase on
leur rase la tête devant leurs enfants
devant leurs parents à eux parce que
vous l'avez dit il ya les grands parents
de tout de suite
la volonté c'est d'humilier tout le
monde ça c'est la première volonté bon
et et puis ils vont emporter vos vos
parents ils vont disparaître vous avez
une soeur aînée elle va faire quoi la
soeur aînée
après comme à cause de cette action donc
tout le monde tous les vases un talent
lui qui sont que ma famille l'autre
famille on a de crédit
créée criminel on descend pourquoi
pourquoi je vous conseille comme des
criminels parce qu'on a c'est donc là je
pas encore compris pourquoi oui tout ça
ça va nous mais c'est plus tard que j'ai
compris parce que mes parents c'est ça
deux intellectuels sont détruits les
comédiens sont des comédiens des
articles et puis aussi votre grand-père
a été banquier
donc c'est évidemment une facette une
fonction qu'on n'apprécie pas beaucoup
lors de la révolution culturelle
alors les parents disparus votre souris
n'a disparu vous restait que vos
grands-parents et maintenant les gars de
rouge vont sans pareil vraiment de votre
grand père
ils vont l'humilier en lui faisant faire
traîner des cailloux et puis un jour
votre grand-père vous le raconter c'est
absolument de scènes atroces
il veut se suicider il se raconte et à
son associé passé
cette chaire racontait parce que j'aime
beaucoup mon grand-père donc je vais
raconter
oui je raconte à votre place cela donc
un jour j'en train de livet journal et
mon grand père rentre à la maison et il
est complètement différent que l'autre
jour parce que notre joue aussi il
rentrait avec des passes de rouge
complet sur le visage mais c'est
toujours là c'était beaucoup plus
bizarre parce que il rentre il parle
tout seul je lui dis bonjour papilles
il n'entend pas et il parle tout seul en
marchant devant moi comment je sais pas
là et puis tout d'un coup ils meurent
tarte avec un duo très gros match très
triste d'une tristesse mais tu me dis
nous nous quand tu sers à cran
il faut pas oublier avoir un pont coeur
et puis mathy dit attaques en mer que je
suis très très très désolé pour elle et
voilà à quoi ces s'est rasé la après ces
trois là il y là prochain table il a
pris un couteau et puis il sortait comme
marionnette il n'est plus rien tant que
c'est là qu'on arrive à susciter mais il
va s'ouvrir les veines mais vous le
sauver avec votre grand mère mais
quelques-uns le lendemain les gars de
rouge arrive parce que ne le voyant pas
au travail et ils vont l'achever ils
vont l'achever à coups de crosse alors à
ce moment là vous êtes à l'école vous
aller à l'école mais vous êtes
évidemment eu ni parce que vous êtes là
la fille des criminels ce que ce qu'on a
pu ni et une scène étonnante c'est que
vous ayez un seul garçon qui vous montre
delà de l'affection de la sympathie il
s'appelle zucchi ans et alors ce bouquin
qui est vraiment un garçon sympathique
qui ne lui s'en fiche et et vous allez
apprendre plus tard qu'il est le fils du
chef des gardes rouges qui sont venus
qui a emmené vos parents qui ont tué
votre grand-père et vous avez que
meilleur ami se ce garçon là ce qui est
ce qui pour vous une évidemment une gt
j'ai été très choqué évidemment comme
son ami tant que c'est plus important
que tous comme j'ai pas des amis donc
mais quand j'appris sage j'étais je
réfléchis beaucoup aussi que j'ai pas
aux i te parlais avec ma commère j'ai
parlé parce que je rentre en pleurant
quand j'ai su ça mc romain me demandait
pourquoi je pleure je dis vous savez
mamie le père de john woo miami ceni qui
a tué mon compère donc ma crevette me
demandais alors pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi tu pleures
il faut que faut pas que tu pleures dit
oui je pleure parce que c'est mon
meilleur ami mais après je me suis dit
avec moussavou digestion de 6 en six ans
et en afrique avec tout ce que moi j'ai
pu imaginer je me suis dit young depuis
le premier jour tout était très gentil
avec toi il faut pas le comment il faut
pas les tests il fait nuit il a rien
fait comment comme j'espère que les
hommes n'est pas responsable
les médecins et puis aussi vos relations
avec un professeur qui est une femme qui
s'appelle professeur yang qui est une
femme admirable
parce que l sais que vous souffrez que
vous êtes humilié vous êtes persécuté
mais elle vous a pris si ça prend de
vous a pris sous sa protection
et puis un jour les gardes rouges elles
aussi vont l'emmener vont l'humilier
devant toute la classe et il demandera
d'ailleurs le chef des rouges demandent
raclent les enfants témoigne contre elle
et tous les enfants refuseront et vous
allez on va la raser aussi pour lui même
chose et vous allez retrouver son
cadavre combien de temps après une
semaine plus tard vous allez retrouver
son cadavre
c'était avec mon meilleur copain jo
tient donc ses nuits kiki c'est vrai
le cadavre de profession parce que son
père s'est toujours céder étrange parce
que c'est de théâtre je plains souvent
bien de ses deux théâtres et quand j'ai
rentré au hall où elle lui a traversé le
noir que j'ai vu il y a quelqu'un qui
assis sur une chaise et c'est mon
professeur yang et elle est déjà mort
mais je ne sais pas encore j'approchais
des linges et i share profession vous
formez réveiller
c'est miu miu parce que j'ai c'est que
même beaucoup donc je crois comme je la
dis que c'est mieux et va réveiller avec
josiane le soleil ou son professeur est
attaché tous les tous les fichiers de
propagande sur elle c'est vrai c'est une
belle scène très bien alors bien entendu
vous souffrez vous du froid de la faim
il ya très peu de chose à manger et vous
montrer que votre corps est recouvert
sans arrêt d'une moisissure espèce de
pustules qu'est ce que c'est vous
souffrez d'une maladie ou bien est ce
que tous ces styles maladie à cause du
froid
un concept sympa assez de manger en plus
ma ville c'est une ville très humide et
puis beaucoup jamais de soleil donc à
quoi s'étaient tous à temps que j'ai
c'est mal acquis et puis bien entendu
vous raconter l'enseignement de mao qui
continue vous devez toujours célébré mao
à toute heure du jour et de la nuit et
toujours vous raconter aussi que
confessé dépêché à mao beaumont pourrait
confesser dépêché à dieu
et puis bon la révolution culturelle va
passer et choses extra venir c'est que
votre ami zukang
je peux pas prononcer comme vous ou
tient donc le chef des gardes rouges
être arrêtée après quand et c'est
lui-même qui va être humilié parce qu'on
va le montrer du doigt on ira soutient
que tu es le fils de celui qui était le
chef des gardes rouges
donc il va devenir ray un enfant
réprouvé comme vous vous lavez et comme
vous vous l'avez été bon et puis vous
allez faire vos études à l'université et
là c'est la deuxième partie du livre
mais vous montrer qu'il n'avait pas été
du tout heureuse à l'université pourquoi
avez vous été malheureuse pourquoi et
finalement pourquoi avez vous quitté
votre pays
quand on était petit daim ce moment là
on a plein de rêves quand la révolution
fini je me suis dit enfin je suis
quelqu'un normale et j'ai fait tout mon
possible pour passer la exams
les jours comme je suis un train pour
arriver à pékin j'ai fini le rêve je
gère mes vieux c'est pour aller au mieux
rester c'est quelque chose de formidable
mais quand je serai dans l'université ça
veut dire trois mois quatre mois plus
tard j'ai toujours que 7,7 un toit ici
c'était pas du tout comme le comme j'ai
dit rêver comme j'arrivais que j'ai
imaginé au contraire c'est qu' il a
certains des choux ce que j'ai vu quand
j'étais petit est toujours continueront
repasse en présent oui la révolution
culturelle était fini mais bien des
choses continuer qui était du futur les
façons d'être les gens comme ils pensent
ça change pas donc et puis vous avez
rencontré un photographe français qui
s'appelle yann et il va vous faire venir
en france et c'est la fin du livre
mais entre temps vous êtes retourné en
chine il y a un an et demi ou deux ans
il ya un an
oui vous et c'est frédéric lafont qui a
fait ce film qui est d'ailleurs passé il
y en n 2 en janvier 88 et je vous
propose de regarder cet extrait où vous
retrouvez votre mère et votre mère qui
nous a jamais raconté qu'en votant vos
parents sont venus qui vous a jamais
raconté les humiliations qu'elle a
subies
voici la question que vous posez à votre
mère depuis qui résout jamais tu ne m'as
parlé de ces années difficiles le peu
que je sache si on sait que france que
tu as dit à mener
ou que j'ai entendu sur la forme
pourquoi tu ne m'a jamais rien dit à moi
quand on fait un cauchemar comme celui
ci comment louis fois réveillés on veut
jamais en aucun cas y repenser on va
faire vraiment plaisir
ne sois pas fâché de bons souvenirs
uniquement je t'aurais parler de terre
promise
si on abandonne ce cauchemar nous a déjà
suffisamment brisé le coeur à tous on
n'a pas le droit de demander aux autres
de partager notre souvent des ouïes
jamais je n'aime pas me dire ils ont ils
sont ils sont restés absents combien
d'années vos parents ce kit à 8 ans dans
des camps de rééducation sont restés
huit ans qui me lefebvre qu'est ce que
vous pensez d'un livre celui ci qui
raconte évidemment une autre aventure
aussi j'ai trouvé ça très très très
intéressant comme documents et j'ai été
très sensible à la souffrance de la
petite fille et il ya un moment très
fort que je trouve c'est quand elle
quand elle a si bien intégré sa haine
qu'elle a battu sa grand mère c'est
comme si elle se battait elle-même et
c'était pour moi le summum de
l'humiliation c'est quand on arrive à se
haïr soi même tellement les joutes les
autres vous lis style certaine et
c'était un moment que j'ai trouvé très
très très fort qu'est ce qui vous fait
rester aujourd'hui à paris c'est vous
êtes mariés jeudi avec yann photographe
c'est l'amour de votre mari qui vous
fait rester en france ou bien vous
aimeriez
au fond si vous n'étiez pas marié seriez
vous retourner en chine même si j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à djibouti fait
connaître mon pays mais c'est un pays
c'est la part que jacques raby sénat pas
que j'ai eus mot culture c'est justement
c'est tout cela parce que tout se le
soleil est de la partie
laird la part qui il vous manque alors
c'est vraiment tout cela il faut choisir
entre la chine ou votre mari
je peux très bien retourné soit pour
voir mes amis mes parents retourner là
bas je peux travailler je me partie
aussi pour que la différence avec mon
histoire justement ce que nous nous et
c'est son pays la chine
c'est un pays qu'ils acceptent même si
elle a souffert dans son propre pays
elle est parmi les siens moi c'est un
pays que j'ai aimés et qui n'a pas voulu
de moi
donc pour moi il n'y a pas de retour
possible et je comprends ils reviennent
oui même votre payer que beaucoup
étaient très très durs qui inquiètent
comme le petit avec 3 mais il a
certaines choses qu on ne faut pas
oublier comme quoi par exemple
je vois pas comment vous réagir ainsi
vous verra jamais votre mère mais pour
moi j'ai dit quelque chose on a vécu
quelque chose que même si c'est mal ça
veut dire comme partie de quelque chose
partir avoue qu' on peut pas un ponton b
et toute ma famille tout vos racines qui
sont là bas alors que pour qu'ils me le
fais ça n'est plus la même chose